Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Are you a man or a woman? A man. Very well then. Adorn a man, not a woman. Woman is born smooth and dainty by nature. And if she is very hairy, she is a prodigy
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你是男的还是女的？男的。那就好。当装扮成男人，而不是女人。女人天生生得光滑娇嫩。如果她毛发很重，那她就是一个怪胎，
and is exhibited at Rome among the prodigies. But for a man not to be hairy is the same thing. And if by nature he has no hair, he is a prodigy. But if he shaves his chin and plucks out his hairs, what shall we make of him? Where shall we exhibit him and what notice shall we post? I will show you, we say to the audience, a man who wishes to be a woman rather than a man. What a dreadful spectacle. So Tom, that was- The wokest man in the Roman Empire. That was Epictetus. He's a philosopher, isn't he? He's having a dialogue.
并在罗马作为怪胎展出。但对男人来说，没有胡须也是一样。如果他天生没有胡须，他就是一个怪胎。但如果他刮掉下巴，拔掉毛发，我们该拿他怎么办？我们该把他放在哪里展出，又该贴出什么样的告示呢？我们会向观众展示，我们说，一个宁愿做女人也不愿做男人的男人。多么可怕的景象。所以，汤姆，那是——罗马帝国最“觉醒”的男人。那是爱比克泰德。他是个哲学家，对吧？他正在进行一场对话。
Stoic philosopher. His views about male grooming, beards, facial hair, and indeed gender more broadly, would be considered controversial today, I think it's fair to say. I think it would, but he's obviously reflecting the mores of the time. He's a fascinating man. He was a former slave. He taught the Emperor Hadrian, among other people. And he points to the way in which the topic of today's episode, namely beards and facial hair, it's about more than just fashion, isn't it? It's about more than grooming. It touches on all kinds of political and philosophical and indeed religious sensitivities. So a fascinating topic. It's bizarre how this topic opens up so many lines of inquiry. Public health,
斯多葛派哲学家。他对男性打理容貌、胡须、面部毛发，乃至更广泛的性别的观点，在今天看来可以说是颇具争议的。我想确实如此，但他显然反映了当时的风气。他是个迷人的人物。他曾是一名奴隶。他曾教导过哈德良皇帝等人。他指出，今天这一集的话题，即胡须和面部毛发，不仅仅关乎时尚，对吧？它不仅仅关乎仪容仪表。它触及了各种政治、哲学甚至是宗教上的敏感神经。所以这是一个引人入胜的话题。这个话题竟然能延伸出这么多探究方向，真是不可思议。公共卫生、
masculinity, the relationship between russia and the west all of these things are wrapped up in the beard absolutely so a great topic also of course i mean it is about fashion and maybe we should kick off just by what's your favorite kind of age of beards your top beards i think if you had to go back in time yeah and grow a beard where would you go? I'd go to the 17th century. Because I think there's a greater diversity of beards in the 17th century than there is in the period. So there's the Van Dyke.
男性气质、俄罗斯与西方之间的关系，所有这些都与胡须紧密相连。绝对是这样，所以这是一个绝佳的话题。当然，这也关乎时尚，也许我们应该先聊聊，你最喜欢的胡须时代是什么？你心中的顶级胡须是怎样的？如果你不得不回到过去，是的，然后留胡子，你会去哪里？我会去17世纪。因为我觉得17世纪的胡须种类比那个时期的其他时候要丰富得多。比如范戴克式胡须。
There's a beard, which I'll be talking about, called a swallowtail with two prongs. There's a spade beard for a soldier. There's creativity. I feel that with the late Victorians, it's just size. It's just an American approach to beards, sort of an emphasis on enormous quantity rather than quality. Yes.
有一种胡须，我待会儿会讲到，叫做燕尾须，有两个分叉。还有一种是给士兵留的铲形胡须。这里面充满了创造力。我觉得晚期维多利亚时代的人，追求的只是尺寸。这只是一种美式对待胡须的方式，某种程度上强调的是极其庞大的数量，而不是质量。是的。
I think I'd go for Elizabethan. Would you? Walter Raleigh, Francis Drake. I like that. The beard of a sea dog. I think that's kind of happy medium and groomed, but there is the hint of sea dog as well. So the beard of a man who, while bearded himself,
我想我会选择伊丽莎白时期。是吗？沃尔特·罗利，弗朗西斯·德雷克。我喜欢那个。海狼的胡须。我觉得那是一种完美的折中，既修剪整洁，但也带着一丝海狼的气质。所以，一个自己留着胡须的男人的胡须，
enjoys singeing the beards of others. Exactly. Yeah. So that would be my choice. Good choice. That's a good choice. I like it. Thanks, Dominic.
却喜欢烧掉别人的胡须。没错。是的。所以这就是我的选择。不错的选择。这是个好选择。我喜欢。谢谢，多米尼克。
Thanks. Anyway, so just an interesting thing about beards before we get into the history is that apparently top scientists don't really know what beards are for. Really? Because I always had a vague sense that beards were a remnant of our simian ancestry. Right. But apparently not, because apparently we actually started growing beards after we'd evolved from whatever it was we were before.
谢谢。总之，在进入历史之前，关于胡须有一个有趣的事实，那就是顶尖科学家其实并不知道胡须是用来干什么的。真的吗？因为我一直有一种模糊的感觉，觉得胡须是我们类人猿祖先的遗留物。对吧。但显然不是，因为据了解，我们实际上是在从某种不知名的远古形态进化而来之后，才开始长出胡须的。
Hold on. No, that's not plausible. So there was a point where human beings were totally hairless. Yes. Well, so bonobos, I think, which are our closest living evolutionary relative, don't have beards. They don't have hair around the mouth. But we males do. So apparently it's an evolutionary conundrum and it worried Darwin. And Darwin's solution was that beards were kind of like the peacock's tail they were designed to attract females and thereby propagate the species because am i right in saying it's a mystery to
等等。不，这不合情理。所以曾有一个阶段，人类是完全没有毛发的。是的。嗯，比如黑猩猩，我认为它们是我们现存最近的进化亲戚，就没有胡须。它们的嘴周围没有毛发。但我们男性有。所以这显然是一个进化之谜，让达尔文很苦恼。达尔文的解决方案是，胡须有点像孔雀的尾巴，它们旨在吸引雌性，从而繁衍后代。因为——我没说错吧，为什么女性没有胡须，这对进化生物学家或无论他们叫什么的人来说是个谜？这完全说不通，或者更切题地说，为什么男性会有胡须？
evolutionary biologists or whatever they're called why women don't have beards it doesn't make any sense or more germanely why men do have beards so apparently the thinking is either that women are attracted to them because they're signifiers of health. So like long, lustrous hair on a woman. Right. Or they are kind of designed to intimidate. So like crests on a lizard or whatever. Yeah.
所以显然大家的想法是，要么女性被它们吸引，因为它们是健康的象征。就像女性长而有光泽的头发一样。对。或者它们旨在起到威慑作用。就像蜥蜴头上的鸡冠之类的。是的。
Going up. Or that they serve no purpose at all. And they're the appendix of outward decorations. Not even like an appendix, because an appendix used to have a reason. I saw Adam Rutherford, top scientist, when we were playing cricket together a couple of days ago and i asked him and he shed no light on it it is apparently an evolutionary mystery so interesting yeah but as we will see the question of what beards signify people have had views on this throughout history and i think when we go through beards in history we're going to be focusing on the kind of the Mediterranean, the Near East, Europe, rather than other areas of the world.
或者它们根本没有目的。它们是外表装饰的盲肠。甚至不像盲肠，因为盲肠过去曾有某种作用。几天前我们一起打板球时，我遇到了顶尖科学家亚当·卢瑟福，我问了他这个问题，但他没有给出任何解释。这显然是一个进化谜团，真是有趣。但正如我们将看到的，关于胡须象征着什么的问题，人们在历史上一直有着各种看法。而且我认为当我们梳理历史上的胡须时，我们将把重点放在地中海、近东、欧洲，而不是世界的其他地区。
Ho Chi Minh's beard will not make an appearance. No, because I don't really know much about them. I mean, Native Americans don't really have beards at all, do they? Sitting Bull didn't have a beard. Crazy Horse, you can't picture them with a beard. You can't even, I can't even imagine. Custer, Custer had a Van Dyke beard. Yeah, and that guy, General Terry, who didn't go to the steamboat.
胡志明的胡子是不会出现的。是的，因为我其实对它们了解不多。我是说，美洲原住民其实根本没有胡须，对吧？坐牛就没有胡子。疯马，你无法想象他们留胡子的样子。你甚至不能——我甚至无法想象。卡斯特，卡斯特留着范戴克式的胡须。是的，还有那个家伙，特里将军，他没去乘汽船。
He had a monster. But I respect Custer that he went for the grooming over the just, oh, let's just grow it. Yeah, I do. I think it was a tendency among late 19th century American presidents and indeed British men of letters to just assume that size meant masculinity or something. Because what Custer got, it's a cavalier beard. And it's all about, you know, Rupert of the Rhine dashing around with cavalry and ending up dead. Yeah, like Custer. So good on him. Anyway, let's go right back to the beginning and look at the cradles
他留着一个怪物般的胡子。但我尊重卡斯特的一点是，他注重修剪，而不是那种“哦，就让它随便长吧”的态度。是的，我确实这么认为。我觉得19世纪晚期的美国总统以及英国文人中，有一种倾向，就是直接认为尺寸意味着男子气概或别的什么。因为卡斯特留的那种，是骑士胡。这完全是关于，你知道的，莱茵河的鲁珀特骑着骑兵四处冲杀，最后战死沙场。是的，就像卡斯特。所以真为他高兴。无论如何，让我们回到起点，来看看欧亚大陆西半部的文明摇篮，
of civilization in the western half of Eurasia, which goes to the Near East and Egypt. And in both those civilizations, what you see is that the beard is interpreted as being a symbol of strength, of aggression, of command. It's associated with warriors, with fighters, with people who sit in judgment. The shaved chins, and indeed shaving more generally, becomes a symbol of purity and closeness to the divine. And so it's associated with scribes and priests. So it's not as though shaving or having a beard, either of those are seen as negatives. Both of them have positive connotations, but they're representative of the different classes
也就是近东和埃及。在这两个文明中，你会发现胡须被解释为力量、攻击性、统治力的象征。它与战士、搏斗者、那些身居审判席的人联系在一起。修剪干净的下巴，乃至更普遍的刮胡子，则成为纯洁和接近神圣的象征。因此，它与书吏和祭司联系在一起。所以这并不是说刮胡子或留胡子其中哪个被视为负面的。两者都有积极的含义，但它们代表了在城市中心出现的不同阶层
of person that emerge in urban centers. And for kings, this obviously represents a challenge because you want to embody both, because a king wants to be a warrior, but he also wants to be close to the gods. And so there are different solutions to this problem are discovered in the Near East and in Egypt. So in Mesopotamia, a king of Sumer called Shulgi, who's on the throne around 2000 BC, he has a tremendous wheeze, which is in some of his statues, he's shown as a bearded warrior. And in others, he's shown as a kind of shaved priest. So he has the best of both worlds. He has his cake and eats it. And Tom, that sense of the beard equaling masculinity on the one hand, martial prowess, and then on the other,
的人。对于国王来说，这显然是一个挑战，因为你想兼具两者，因为国王既想成为一名战士，又想接近神明。因此，近东和埃及的人们发现了解决这个问题的不同方法。在美索不达米亚，有一位苏美尔国王名叫舒尔吉，他在公元前2000年左右登上王位，他有一个绝妙的点子，就是在他的某些雕像中，他被描绘成一个留着胡须的战士。而在另一些雕像中，他被描绘成一个刮得精光的祭司。所以他两全其美。他鱼与熊掌兼得。汤姆，那种一方面胡须等于男子气概、尚武精神，另一方面修剪胡须和光洁的面庞代表纯洁、干净、某种精神上的纯洁。
shaving and a clean face being pure, clean, kind of spiritually clean. Clean cut. Yeah. Clean cut, disciplined, maybe a sort of asceticism and austerity, a kind of moral austerity. That runs right through the centuries, indeed the millennia. Yeah. And it's amazing when you trace it through, as we'll be doing. But I think in Mesopotamia, kings do end up kind of portraying themselves as bearded. So the Assyrians, the Babylonians, the Persians, you think of the portrayals of Persian kings,
利落的剪裁。是的。干净利落、纪律严明，也许带有一种苦行僧式的简朴和严肃，一种道德上的严厉。这种观念贯穿了几个世纪，甚至几千年。是的。当你顺着这条线索追溯时，这真是令人惊叹，正如我们将会做的那样。但我认为在美索不达米亚，国王们最终还是把自己塑造成留胡子的形象。所以亚述人、巴比伦人、波斯人，你想象一下对波斯国王的描绘，
they're very kind of long, a bit like, um, the beard that our producer Theo had until the weekend when he, he shaved it off. He did, especially for this podcast. Which I regret because he could have woven ribbons into it and adornments like the Persian kings did. He'd look lovely. Yeah, he'd look really, really good. And you can see how completely associated with royal authority the beard is. There's a wonderful story told by the Greek historian, Theseus, who's talking about an
他们留着那种很长的胡子，有点像，嗯，我们的制作人西奥直到周末之前一直留着的胡子，当时他——把它刮掉了。他确实刮了，特意为了这个播客。我对此感到遗憾，因为他本来可以把缎带编进胡子里，就像波斯国王那样挂上装饰品。他看起来会很可爱。是的，他看起来会非常非常帅。你可以看到胡须与王权是多么地密不可分。希腊历史学家忒修斯讲过一个精彩的故事，他谈到了一个
ambitious eunuch who is conspiring against his master, the king. And he has a woman in the court make him a full beard and moustache so that he will have the appearance not just of a man, but of a king. And I guess that that's kind of interesting because it suggests two things. The first is that maybe one of the reasons for keeping eunuchs in the court of Mesopotamian kings, Persian kings, is precisely to emphasize the hirsute quality of masculine majesty. Yeah. Obviously, there's an entire cottage industry in these courts of women making beards and
野心勃勃的太监，正阴谋反对他的主子——国王。他让宫廷里的一位女性为他制作了一副浓密的胡须和小胡子，这样他不仅能拥有男人的外表，还能拥有国王的外表。我想这挺有意思的，因为它暗示了两点。首先，在美索不达米亚国王和波斯国王的宫廷里保留太监的原因之一，可能正是为了强调男性威严的浓密毛发特征。是的。显然，这些宫廷里存在着一个完整的产业，由女性制作胡须和
mustaches. Well, as we'll see, there were people who did that and made a lot of money from it in the 1960s. Male order mustaches were a thing. Well, there's nothing new under the sun, is there? No. Just on the eunuchs. If you're a eunuch, are you incapable of growing a beard?
小胡子。嗯，正如我们将看到的，在20世纪60年代，确实有人这样做并通过此赚了大钱。邮购小胡子曾风靡一时。嗯，太阳底下无新事，对吧？是的。顺便说一下太监的事。如果你是个太监，你是无法长出胡须的吗？
I think it depends on when the operation happens. Okay. I don't know if we have people who are experts in that. Maybe they could let us know. If there are any eunuchs listening to the podcast, you'd like to get in touch. Well, eunuchologists. But obviously, I mean, one of the reasons for castrating boys is to prevent them from growing beards.
我觉得这取决于手术发生的时间。好吧。我不知道我们是否有这方面的专家。也许他们可以告诉我们。如果有任何太监在听这个播客，你们愿意联系我们吗？嗯，太监学者。但很显然，我的意思是，阉割男孩的原因之一就是为了防止他们长出胡须。
Understood. So that they stay clean shaven right the way through. And hence that thing about purity. Presumably there's a belief that they're somehow more pure? No, because it's seen as cheating. Oh, okay. Fair enough. So that's Mesopotamia.
明白了。这样他们就能一直保持光洁无须的状态。因此也就有了那种关于纯洁的说法。大概人们有一种信仰，认为他们某种程度上更加纯洁？不，因为这被视为作弊。哦，好吧。那倒也是。这就是美索不达米亚。
We've done that. So let's move on to Egypt, which of course is the other great centre of early civilisation. And there you have the same thing, because there's a massive premium on shaving in Egypt. Bodily purity is huge, and it's not just priests who really go all in. They shave completely over their body, shave their head and everything, but nobles do as well. And so that's why they will wear the wigs, the famous wigs that everyone will have seen on the tomb illustrations.
我们讲完了。那么让我们转向埃及，当然，那是早期文明的另一个伟大中心。在那里你也会发现同样的情况，因为在埃及，人们极度重视刮胡子。身体纯洁至关重要，而且不仅仅是祭司们全力以赴。他们不仅把全身的毛发刮得精光，还剃光了头等等，贵族们也是如此。这就是为什么他们会戴假发，也就是每个人在陵墓插图上都能看到的那些著名的假发。
And essentially the only person who wears a beard in Egypt is the king, is Pharaoh. But he gets around this idea that he wants to portray himself as being pure as well by making it clear that the beard is very obviously a false one. Yeah, it's got a chin strap, hasn't it? It's a chin strap beard. Yeah, exactly. And it's shown on the kind of the portrayals of kings in tombs or whatever, or statues. And that's why it works for Hatshepsut, the female pharaoh who presents herself as a male pharaoh.
从本质上讲，在埃及唯一留胡子的人就是国王，也就是法老。但他通过明确表示胡须显然是假的，来绕过他同样想把自己塑造成纯洁形象的想法。是的，它有一个下巴带，对吧？那是一个带下巴带的胡须。对，没错。而且它在陵墓等地的国王画像或雕像中都有展示。这就是为什么它对哈特谢普苏特行得通，这位把自己表现为男性法老的女性法老。
The artificiality of the beard to an Egyptian, I think, wouldn't have seemed as discordant, perhaps, as it does to us. Because they're used to people wearing full spears. So the fact that she's wearing one is not so peculiar. Yeah. And I think it really matters precisely because that association of complete bodily smoothness and its association with divinity is so strong in Egypt. So when Herodotus goes to Egypt, he's astounded by the smoothness of Egyptian priests.
对于一个埃及人来说，胡须的人工痕迹可能不会像对我们那样显得那么不和谐。因为他们习惯了人们佩戴各种假胡须。所以她戴着一个并不显得那么奇特。是的。而且我认为这至关重要，正是因为埃及人对完全平滑的身体及其与神圣联系的这种观念是如此强烈。因此，当希罗多德去埃及旅游时，他被埃及祭司的光滑程度惊呆了。
So he writes, priests will give themselves a full body shave every other day. This is done to prevent them from sheltering lice or any other vermin while they minister to the gods. So very Herodotian that he would focus on the lice. That sense that you can't go in teeming with lice when you're offering sacrifice to the gods. I mean, that's what's going on. But it does point to the way in which actually not just the Greeks, but also the Jews as well, the two peoples who've been most influential on the course of Western history, they do have slightly different attitudes to beards, well, actually very different attitudes to beards. So looking at the Jews first, what's distinctive about them, I think, is that they enshrine the beard as a symbol of purity. So, I mean, that's like circumcision. It becomes a marker of the distinctiveness of the Israelites,
于是他写道：祭司们每隔一天就会把全身刮得精光。这样做是为了防止他们在侍奉神明时藏匿虱子或任何其他害虫。他把重点放在虱子上，真是太具希罗多德的风格了。那种当你向神明献祭时，身上不能爬满虱子的意识。我的意思是，这就是当时的真实情况。但这确实表明，不仅是希腊人，还有犹太人，这两个对西方历史进程影响最深远的人民，他们对胡须的态度略有不同——实际上是截然不同。所以先来看看犹太人，他们的独特之处在于，我认为，他们将胡须奉为纯洁的象征。所以，这意味着这就像割礼一样。它成了以色列人、
the Jews, whatever. And that's almost certainly, surely, defining themselves against their superpower neighbours. So doing the opposite, merely to make themselves distinctive. And then that gets stuck they get stuck with it yeah well they get stuck with it or they've been told to do it by god and so therefore they cleave to it as a marker of their divine election i mean two ways of two ways of putting it yeah and that's something that gets in the long run inherited by christians we look at christians actually have quite ambivalent attitudes to beards, but Muslims definitely, because they are enshrining Muhammad as the last in a long line of patriarchs that you get in the Bible. And so it's taken for granted that Muhammad
犹太人等群体独特性的一种标志。这几乎可以肯定、毫无疑问是他们在与超级大国的邻居们划清界限。因此采取相反的做法，纯粹是为了让自己显得与众不同。然后他们就被套进去了，他们被这个传统缠住了。嗯，他们被套进去了，或者这是上帝命令他们这样做的，因此他们紧紧抓住这一点，作为他们获得神圣拣选的标志——这是两种不同的说法，对吧？是的，这也是基督徒最终继承的东西。我们看看基督徒其实对胡须有着相当矛盾的态度，但穆斯林绝对是坚定的，因为他们将穆罕默德奉为《圣经》中漫长先知谱系中的最后一位。因此，人们理所当然地认为穆罕默德
was bearded. I mean, there's actually, I don't think a single mention of beards in the Quran, but the idea that Muhammad is bearded, it appears in the hadiths and in the lives of Muhammad. And so that's why to this day, so many Muslim men are bearded, and particularly those who are kind of going back to the original sources. But going back to the Jews in antiquity, their hairiness creates a massive point of tension with the empire that succeeds the Persians in ruling them, which is that of Alexander the Great. Right. I thought we'd come to Alexander. Because I think there's a case for saying that in the history of the beard, Alexander the Great is perhaps the single most influential figure. Totally is.
是留着胡须的。我的意思是，事实上，我認為《古兰经》中甚至没有一次提到胡须，但穆罕默德留着胡须的观点出现在了圣训和穆罕默德的生平传记中。这就是为什么直到今天，如此多的穆斯林男性都留着胡须，尤其是那些试图回归原始经典的人。但回到古代的犹太人，他们的多毛特质与统治他们的波斯帝国的继承者——亚历山大大帝——之间产生了巨大的紧张关系。对。我还以为我们要讲到亚历山大呢。因为我觉得有理由认为，在胡须的历史中，亚历山大大帝或许是其中最具影响力的人物。绝对是的。
And the reason for that is that before Alexander, so in Greece in the classical period, I mean, the Greeks loved a beard as well. So you think of Zeus, a mighty beard, absolutely emblematic of his role as king of gods, Heracles, the strongest of the heroes. I mean, he has a big beard and there's clearly quite a strong sexual dynamic to this. So in Aristophanes, the great comic writer in Athens in the fifth century, men who shave or don't have beards at all are seen as kind of comically effeminate, and he's always making jokes about it. And it must be influenced by the practice of pederasty in Athens, that beards are the emblem of the older active partner in that kind of relationship. And a smooth chin is emblematic of youth and of kind of relative degree of passivity in the relationship. So it kind of eroticizes it.
原因在于，在亚历山大之前，也就是古典时期的希腊，希腊人其实也很喜欢胡须。想想宙斯，那一脸威严的胡须，绝对象征着他作为众神之王的地位；赫拉克勒斯，最强壮的英雄，他留着大胡子，这显然带有相当强烈的性暗示。因此，在公元前5世纪雅典伟大的喜剧作家阿里斯托芬的作品中，那些刮胡子或根本不留胡子的人被视为具有滑稽的女性化特征，他总是拿这个开玩笑。这一定受到了雅典娈童习俗的影响，胡须是这种关系中较年长、占据主动的一方的标志。而光洁的下巴则象征着年轻以及在这段关系中相对被动的程度。所以它给这种关系增添了色情色彩。
And there isn't the kind of theological dimension that you get in the Near East to it. But philosophers also tend to be very keen on beards. So actually the beard is always the kind of the emblem of the philosopher. And Aristotle, his theory on beards is So actually the beard is always the emblem of the philosopher. And Aristotle, his theory on beards is what underpins Epictetus' take on it. That what generates a beard is the hot fluids that men, as opposed to women, have, and particularly dominic semen. So the more semen you have, the bigger the beard. But of course, the more semen you have, the likely you are to have sex. And the more semen you have the likely you are to have sex and the more you have sex the like you are to be bald so cranky well what does that yeah yeah but some this is a theme that runs
这其中并没有你在近东所看到的那种神学维度。但哲学家们也往往非常喜欢胡须。事实上，胡子一直是哲学家标志性的特征。亚里士多德关于胡子的理论是——所以事实上，胡子一直是哲学家的标志。亚里士多德关于胡子的理论支撑了爱比克泰德的观点。产生胡须的原因是男性（而不是女性）体内的热性体液，尤其是多米尼克所说的精液。因此，你的精液越多，胡子就越大。当然，你的精液越多，你就越有可能进行性行为。你的精液越多，你就越有可能进行性行为，而你的性行为越多，你就越容易秃头。真是个怪论。好吧，这有什么关系呢——是的，但这是贯穿胡须历史的一个主题，因为正如我们将在下半部分看到的，人们直到近代早期仍然深信不疑，关于热度、生育力和胡子这一套理论，是一个长期存在的主题。
through the history of the beard because as we'll see in the second half people believe this well into the early modern period this business about heat fertility and beards is a is a long-running theme. Well, because as we'll see, it feeds into medicine as well. Yes. So Hippocrates and then Galen. And this then goes into the bloodstream of medieval attitudes to this and the Renaissance and so on.
嗯，因为正如我们将看到的，它也融入了医学之中。是的。所以从希波克拉底到盖伦。随后这些又融入了中世纪对这一问题的态度以及文艺复兴等等的血液中。
So very, very influential take on beards. But at the same time, you do also have, I think, the sense that you get in other ancient cultures, that a smooth chin can be an expression of the divine, but a kind of subversive, discordant, unsettling form of divinity. So Apollo, Hermes are often portrayed as gods without beards. And the combination of youth and power is unsettling to the Greeks. Likewise with Achilles, the great Greek hero at Troy, he is disguised as a woman, as a girl. And Odysseus discovers him by going to this place where he's hidden with all the girls.
所以这是一个非常非常有影响力的关于胡子的观点。但与此同时，你也确实拥有那种你在其他古代文化中看到的观念，即光滑的下巴可以是对神圣的一种表达，但却是一种颠覆性的、不和谐的、令人不安的神圣形式。因此，阿波罗、赫尔墨斯通常被描绘成没有胡须的神明。青春与力量的结合让希腊人感到不安。同样，对于阿喀琉斯这位在特洛伊的伟大希腊英雄来说，他曾被伪装成一个女人、一个女孩。奥德修斯通过来到他与所有女孩藏身的地方找到了他。
And he's got a great sack full of jewelry and so on, but with a sword. And Achilles reaches for the sword and kind of draws it out. And this reveals that he's actually who he is. So off he goes to Troy. So the shaven face is unearthly. Is that it? It's slightly unsettling. Yes, unsettling.
他带着一大麻袋珠宝等等，但还藏着一把剑。阿喀琉斯伸手去拿剑，并将其拔了出来。这暴露了他其实是谁。于是他出发去了特洛伊。所以，刮得精光的面孔是超凡脱俗的。是这样吗？它稍微有点令人不安。是的，令人不安。
And actually, you get it the other way around. So Herodotus has this wonderful report of a priestess of Athena at a place called Pedassa, which is just outside Halicarnassus, today bodrum where herodotus came from and she whenever danger threatened would always grow a beard so this was a kind of long-range crisis you know you'd go and see whether she'd sprouted some whiskers or not and if she had you'd button down the hatches. But I think that sense of the strangeness, the potential power, the eeriness of someone who is very, very powerful and indisputably a great warrior, choosing to portray himself as smooth-chinned is what Alexander is about, because it's scrambling people's cultural expectations in Greece.
事实上，情况有时会反过来。因此，希罗多德有一段精彩的记录，讲述了一位雅典娜女祭司在一个叫佩达萨的地方的故事，该地就在哈利卡那索斯郊外，也就是今天的博德姆，希罗多德的故乡。每当危险逼近时，她总是会留起胡子——所以这成了一种长期的危机预警，你知道的，人们会去看看她是不是长出了一些胡须。如果她长了，你就会严阵以待。但我认为，那种陌生感、潜在的力量感、一个非常非常强大且无可争议的伟大战士选择将自己描绘成无须之人的诡异感，正是亚历山大所代表的，因为这颠覆了希腊人的文化预期。
So his father, Philip II, king who builds the Macedonian war machine, big beard, masculine, wants to look like Zeus, I assume, or Heracles. Alexander, on his coins, is always clean shaven, isn't he? And his statues. Yeah. I mean, I think he's young, isn't he? That's the difference. So Philip is mature. I mean, I think he's young, isn't he? That's the difference. So Philip is, you know, he's mature. He can play Zeus. He's grizzled. Alexander,
所以他的父亲，马其顿战争机器的缔造者菲利普二世，留着大胡子，充满男子气概，我猜他想让自己看起来像宙斯或赫拉克勒斯。而亚历山大在硬币上的形象总是光着下巴的，对吧？还有他的雕像。是的。我的意思是，我觉得他很年轻，对吧？这就是区别。所以菲利普比较成熟。我是说，我觉得他很年轻，对吧？这就是区别。所以菲利普，你知道的，他很成熟。他能扮演宙斯。他饱经风霜。而亚历山大，
because he has inherited the throne at a very young age, he's making an advantage of it. He's portraying himself, I mean, above all as Achilles. Achilles is his great role model. But there is also a sense of, you know, the younger generation of Olympians. Like Apollo or somebody. Yeah. And just to say that there were alternative theories about this that were proffered in antiquity. So Plutarch, he advances the theory that Alexander ordered his men to shave off all their beards. So it wasn't just Alexander doing it. All of them were because he was worried that the enemy would reach out and grab them. I think that's such obvious nonsense. You're dissing Plutarch.
因为他很年轻就继承了王位，所以他把这一点转化为了优势。他把自己塑造成——最重要的是——阿喀琉斯。阿喀琉斯是他伟大的榜样。但这也有一种新一代奥林匹斯神的感觉。就像阿波罗或者其他人。是的。顺便说一下，古代曾有人提出过关于这一现象的其他理论。比如普鲁塔克，他提出了一种理论，称亚历山大下令他的手下刮掉所有的胡须。所以不仅仅是亚历山大一个人这么做。所有人都在这么做，因为他担心敌人会伸手抓住它们的胡子。我觉得这显然是无稽之谈。你在贬低普鲁塔克。
I love Plutarch, but I don't think it's plausible. A, that no general would have thought of this before, or B, that the having or non-having of a beard would really make the difference in the battle against the Persians. Because it's a kind of just-so story, isn't it? Yeah. And clearly Plutarch, who's an antiquarian, he completely recognises the fact, the scale of how different Alexander's look is relative to all the great generals who had gone
我喜欢普鲁塔克，但我觉得这不合情理。A，没有哪个将领会在此之前想不到这一点；B，有没有胡子并不会真正对与波斯人的战斗产生决定性的影响。因为这只是一种“马后炮”式的解释，对吧？是的。而且显然普鲁塔克作为一位古物学者，他完全意识到了这样一个事实，即亚历山大的外表与他之前的所有伟大将领相比，存在着巨大的差异，而之前的所有将领都是留着胡子的。他显然在四处寻找解释，我想古希腊人大概也是如此。我认为这反映了亚历山大是多么具有变革性。对于回顾历史的人来说，这似乎是一个令人困惑、非同寻常且需要解释的现象。但我认为，其解释相当明显，即亚历山大是在将自己塑造成一种独特的神明。对。因为几乎我们可以想到的亚历山大之前的所有古代统治者，几乎每一个人都留着胡子，而且他们大概——即使他们真的长不出胡子，也会把自己塑造成留着胡子的形象，
before him, all of whom were bearded. And he's kind of clearly looking around for an explanation, as I guess the Greeks were generally. And I think that that's reflective of just how transformative Alexander is. It's something that does seem to people looking back as kind of puzzling and extraordinary and needing an explanation. But I think the explanation is pretty clearly that Alexander is portraying himself as a distinctive kind of God. Right. Because almost every ancient ruler that we can think of before Alexander, every single one has a beard pretty much and they would presumably even if they couldn't really grow a beard they would portray themselves with the beard
不管怎样，因为他们想看起来尚武、强壮、强大，就像哈特谢普苏特那样——是的，或者他们会戴假胡子。但亚历山大——所以亚历山大是真正的颠覆性创新，这就是为什么我认为，在胡须的历史上，他是第一名。他是第一名。如果你想了解更多关于这方面的内容，有一本很棒的儿童读物，对吧？是的，确实有。
anyway because they want to look martial strong powerful like hatchet said yeah or they'd have fake beard but alex so alexander is genuinely transformative completely which is why i think you know he is in the history of the beard he is the number one he's the number one and if you want to know more about this there's a brilliant children's book, isn't there? Yeah, there is. That touches on this very issue. And which may inspire young readers when they grow up to grow a beard. No, to shave.
这本书就涉及了这个非常具体的问题。并且可能会激励年轻读者在他们长大后留胡子。不，是刮胡子。
Oh, sorry, to shave, yes. Yeah. They won't want to look like Darius or Bessus. They'll want to look like Alexander. Or Baguas, the eunuch. I don't think that's a terrible role model for young readers. Well, this is the perils of writing for children, isn't it?
哦，抱歉，是刮胡子，对。是的。他们可不想看起来像大流士或者贝苏斯。他们会想看起来像亚历山大。或者像太监巴古阿斯。我觉得这对年轻读者来说不算是一个糟糕的榜样。好吧，这就是为儿童写作的风险所在，不是吗？
It is. So on that bombshell, listen, we'll take a break and let's return after the break, Tom, because I am very interested in Roman beards and I know there's nobody better to dispense wisdom on that topic than you. launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we are talking beards tom we got up to alexander the single most important person in the history of the male face.
确实如此。带着这个重磅炸弹，听众朋友们，我们先休息一下，休息回来之后，汤姆，因为我对罗马的胡须非常感兴趣，而且我知道没有人比你更适合在这个话题上发表高见了。我们推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并优先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们在聊胡子，汤姆。我们讲到了亚历山大，他是男性面部历史的最重要人物。
And now we turn to the Romans. Now, I'm showing my ignorance here. I'm guessing like 99% of the listeners, when I think of the Romans, if I'm not thinking of Hadrian or somebody who's been self-consciously Greek, then I'm thinking of very sort of very clean shaven men, men who shave so closely because that's part of their Republican austerity and distinguishing themselves from the astute luxuriance of Eastern decadence. Am I right? Well, I think that to begin with, the Romans have the traditional association of beards with
现在我们转向罗马人。现在，我在这里表现出了我的无知。我猜和99%的听众一样，当我想到罗马人时，如果我想的不是哈德良或者其他那种有意识地表现得像希腊人的人，那么我想象到的都是非常、非常刮得精光的男人，他们之所以把胡子刮得这么干净，是因为那是他们共和政体简朴作风的一部分，也是为了将自己与东方颓废奢华的毛发区分开来。我说的对吗？嗯，我认为一开始，罗马人确实有着将胡须与尚武精神、
martial valour and in fact with republican virtue. There's a famous portrait bust that is supposed to be of Brutus, the man who expelled the monarchy and established the republic. In fact, it probably isn't, but it's telling that that association is made by later generations. The man who establishes the Republic in Rome is felt, people clearly feel should be bearded. There's a story that is told about the sack of Rome by the Gauls in 390 BC, where the Gauls have broken into the city. And the senators, rather than fleeing, have chosen to sit in state in the Senate house.
甚至与共和美德联系在一起的传统。有一尊著名的肖像半身胸像，据说是布鲁图斯的，也就是那个驱逐君主制、建立共和国的人。事实上，它可能并不是，但这种关联被后代做出，是很有说明意义的。人们显然觉得，在罗马建立共和国的那个人应该留着胡子。有一个关于公元前390年高卢人洗劫罗马的故事，当时高卢人已经攻入了城市。元老们没有逃跑，而是选择在元老院大厅里正襟危坐。
They're in their robes, they have their staffs, and they are sat there with their tremendous flowing beards. And the ghouls break into the Senate House and they are struck dumb with awe at the spectacle of this incredible array of distinguished looking men. And they're not sure whether they're statues or flesh and blood. And so one of them goes up to a senator and tugs on his beard. And as we'll see, the tugging on a beard is traditionally seen as a mortal insult. And so the senator reaches up with his staff and hits the Gaul. And the Gaul responds by drawing his sword, hacking him to death. And all the Senate are massacred. I mean, that is one of the versions of the story.
他们穿着长袍，拿着手杖，坐在那里，留着极其浓密飘逸的胡须。高卢人闯入元老院大厅，被这群穿着惊人、外表尊贵的男人的景象震得目瞪口呆。他们不确定这些到底是雕像还是血肉之躯。于是其中一人走到一位元老面前，拉扯他的胡子。正如我们所见，拉扯胡子传统上被视为一种致命的侮辱。于是这位元老举起手杖打了那个高卢人。高卢人则拔出剑，将他乱刀砍死。接着所有元老都被屠杀了。我的意思是，这是该故事的版本之一。
And it's dependent on the assumption that senators in particular, and the word senator derives from Senex, the Latin for old man, that they would have beards and that the beard would be an emblem of their authority and their prestige. So obviously later on in Roman history, they're enormous fans of Alexander. So Pompey the Great, you know, does his hair like Alexander's and wears Alexander's cloak or claims to. So after Alexander's death, does the news of
这取决于这样一种假设：元老们尤其是这样——“元老”（senator）这个词源于“Senex”，即拉丁语中的“老头”——他们应该留有胡子，而且胡子是他们权威和威望的象征。因此，在罗马历史的后期，他们极其崇拜亚历山大。所以庞培大帝（你知道的）把头发弄成亚历山大的样子，还穿着亚历山大的斗篷，或者声称自己穿着。那么在亚历山大死后，他光着下巴的消息传到罗马了吗，然后大家都争相模仿？那是怎么运作的？我的意思是，你说罗马人是亚历山大的粉丝。我觉得这其中的态度要矛盾得多。亚历山大是希腊人，而罗马人总是——我的意思是，他们对希腊人抱有一定的文化自卑感，但他们同时也看不起希腊人。他们是正在崛起的强权。他们最终征服了希腊人。因此有一种感觉，当亚历山大无须面庞的榜样开始向西渗透进入罗马人的势力范围时，它引发了一场文化战争，因为那些采用亚历山大式刮胡子风格的人，立刻将自己与对希腊文化的热情联系在了一起。而那些对胡子保持喜爱的罗马人，
his clean shavenness reach Rome and they all rush to copy it? Or how does that work? I mean, you say that the Romans are fans of Alexander. I think it's more ambivalent than that. Alexander is Greek and the Romans always, I mean, they have a degree of cultural cringe towards the Greeks, but they do also feel contemptuous of them. They are the rising power. They end up conquering the Greeks. And so there is a sense, the moment that the example of Alexander's clean-shaved face starts to percolate westwards into the Roman sphere of influence, it generates a kind of culture war because those who adopt the Alexander style of shaving immediately associate themselves with an enthusiasm for Greek culture. And those Romans who maintain a fondness for the beard
他的洁面无须传到了罗马，然后大家都争相效仿？或者说这是怎么运作的？我的意思是，你说罗马人是亚历山大迷。我认为情况要矛盾得多。亚历山大是希腊人，而罗马人总是——我的意思是，他们对希腊人有一种程度上的文化自卑，但他们也确实对希腊人感到蔑视。他们是正在崛起的势力。他们最终征服了希腊人。因此有一种感觉，当亚历山大无须面庞的榜样开始渗透到罗马的势力范围向西传播时，它引发了一种文化战争，因为那些采用亚历山大式刮胡子风格的人立即将自己与对希腊文化的热情联系在一起。而那些保持对胡须喜好的罗马人
are casting themselves as traditionalists, as people who don't go in for that kind of nonsense. So the fun thing there is that's a total reversal of what happens later on under the empire, which is the thing that is better known, which is when Hadrian has his beard and he's seen as being very Hellenophile yeah and i think it's telling that the first roman who who really goes in for this he's cast as a kind of fashion victim as someone
则把自己塑造成传统主义者，是不搞这种无聊把戏的人。所以有趣的是，这与后来帝国统治下发生的情况完全相反，那是更为人所熟知的现象，即哈德良留着胡子，并被视为狂热的希腊文化崇拜者。是的，而且我认为这很有说明意义，第一个真正热衷于此的罗马人，被塑造成了一种时尚受害者，一个屈服于这种风格、这种享乐、以及这种西西里希腊城市所能提供的潜在非罗马化行事方式的人。
who is succumbing to the style to the pleasures to the potentially un-roman way of doing things that the cities in greek cities in Sicily have to offer. Because he's been campaigning there. He has obtained a barber and he brings this barber back with him to Rome, rather in the way that later on, Romans who go to Asia Minor when they've conquered that will bring back celebrity chefs with their talent for Greek fine cooking. and so it generates a kind of culture war and the person who according to pliny writing about it much later is the first to shave daily which is you know a kind of massive extension of this mania for clean shaving to do it daily i mean absolutely extraordinary is scipio africanus who is the man who defeats Hannibal, Rome's greatest general, is often
因为他曾在那里进行过军事远征。他在那里找了一个理发师，并把这个理发师带回了罗马，这有点像后来那些征服了小亚细亚的罗马人在获胜后会带回擅长希腊精细烹饪的名厨一样。这引发了一场文化战争，根据后来写下这段历史的普鲁塔克的说法，第一个每天刮胡子的人——你知道的，这是对这种追求面部光滑狂热的巨大延伸，竟然要每天都刮——简直令人难以置信，他就是西庇阿·非洲各（Scipio Africanus）。他是击败了汉尼拔的人、罗马最伟大的将领，他常常
associated with Alexander the Great because of his generalship, is clearly also kind of making play with that sense of Alexander as divine. And so Scipio is viewed with deep suspicion by conservative critics. And he eventually ends up kind of being, you know, he goes into forced retirement because the Republican strain in Rome is so suspicious of what his clean-shaven chin suggests that he's, you know, they worry that he's planning basically to make himself into an Alexander, make himself into a king. Oh, crikey. I didn't, I was about to say he could get away with it because of his martial record, but clearly he couldn't. But I guess it's symbolic, isn't it? I mean, he's not forced into exile because he shaves every day.
因为他的将帅之才而与亚历山大大帝联系在一起，显然也在某种程度上利用了将亚历山大视同神明的这种观念。因此，西庇阿受到了保守派评论员的深深怀疑。他最终以某种方式——你知道的，他被迫退休了，因为罗马的共和派传统对他的无须下巴所暗示的意图感到极其怀疑，他们担心他基本上是在策划让自己变成另一个亚历山大，让自己成为一个国王。哦，天哪。我差点想说，凭借他的赫赫战功，他本可以逃过一劫，但显然他没能做到。但我猜这是象征性的，对吧？我的意思是，他并不是因为每天刮胡子而被流放的。
But it's all part of the package. The Romans don't want overweening military figures because that threatens the security of the Republic. Right. And a guy who has defeated Hannibal, who then clean-shaves himself every day, he's symbolising the way in which he's a threat. I guess it's a little bit like if a British politician, if somebody, you know, if Robert Jenrick,
但这都是整体的一部分。罗马人不希望出现权倾朝野的军事人物，因为这会威胁到共和国的安全。对。一个击败了汉尼拔、然后每天把胡子刮得精光的家伙，他正在象征性地展示他是一个潜在的威胁。我想这有点像如果一个英国政客，如果有人——你知道的，如果正在竞选保守党领袖的罗伯特·杰里克（Robert Jenrick），
who is standing to be leader of the Conservatives, appeared with a sort of toothbrush moustache. Yes, exactly. That would raise eyebrows, wouldn't it? I think it would. And if he said, oh, it's perfectly innocent, it's just... So at what point do the Romans start shaving? Because they do start shaving...
顶着某种牙刷须出现。是的，没错。那会让人侧目，对吧？我想会的。如果他说，“哦，这完全是无辜的，这只是……”那么，罗马人是从什么时候开始刮胡子的？因为他们确实开始刮胡子了——
Well, they do. I mean, they're doing it because it's fashionable and because it's a strong look and because Greek culture is very influential and because that's the definition of a culture war. You have conservatives and you have people who are experimenting with the new options, the new opportunities that Rome's conquest of the Mediterranean is opening up. And I would say that by the first century BC, so the age of Julius Caesar and Pompey, who, as you said, famously clean-shaven, beards are still a feature of upper-class life. So you do have people who maintain them. By this point, they're kind of becoming hipster beards. So they're styled,
嗯，他们确实在刮。我的意思是，他们这样做是因为这很时髦，因为这是一种很有气场的造型，因为希腊文化极具影响力，而且因为这就是文化战争的定义。你既有保守派，也有那些正在尝试新选择、尝试罗马征服地中海所带来的新机遇的人。我想说，到公元前1世纪，也就是凯撒大帝和庞培的时代——正如你所说，他们俩都是著名的无须者——胡子仍然是上流社会生活的一个特征。所以你确实能看到有人保留胡子。到了这个时候，它们有点变成了潮人胡子。所以它们是经过造型的，
they're trimmed. Cicero himself is clean-shaven, but he calls those who have these hipster beards, the beni barbati, the well bearded, those who are finely groomed, those who are finely trimmed. And increasingly, the point at which you have your first shave actually comes to be seen as the marker of masculinity, of becoming mature, of becoming a man. So in a way, it's kind of the reversal because classically, of course, your first beard, that shows that you've become a man. But to get rid of the beard by the time Nero, for instance, makes a great palaver of it, the emperor in the first century AD. Do you have a golden box or something? Golden box. He presents it, takes it up to the capitol it's all kind of great cheering and everything and nero is bene babati so the busts of him the beard runs under his chin and then stops under the chin he's got a terrible beard i quite like it i quite like it i think it i think you saw somebody like that if somebody served you in a coffee shop with that beard i think you'd be unsettled well have you seen the wax work you know, the model of him based on the...
是修剪过的。西塞罗本人是刮得精光的，但他把那些留着潮人胡子的人称为“beni barbati”，即胡须修剪精美的人、那些打扮精致的人、那些修剪得一丝不苟的人。而且越来越明显的是，你第一次刮胡子的那个时间点，实际上成了男子气概、走向成熟、成为男人的标志。所以从某种程度上说，这是一种颠覆，因为在传统上，当然是你长出的第一把胡子表明你成为了一个男人。但摆脱胡子——比如尼禄，公元前1世纪的皇帝，就大肆宣扬过这一点。你有一个金盒子什么的吗？金盒子。他把它呈上来，送到卡皮托利山上，伴随着巨大的欢呼声等等，而且尼禄自己就是“beni barbati”，所以他的半身像上，胡子顺着下巴延伸然后到下巴下方就停住了。他留着一个可怕的胡子。我挺喜欢的。我挺喜欢的。我觉得如果你去咖啡店，有人顶着那样一个胡子为你服务，你会感到不安。好吧，你见过那个蜡像吗，你知道的，根据那个……
Yes, the 3D thing. I mean, he looks very, very sinister. Anyway, so either you're clean shaven or it's groomed and trimmed and styled. Yeah. And the corollary of that is that unkempt beards increasingly become the kind of the marker of a plebeian status. And it reflects the fact that actually, which we haven't really talked about until now, that having a shave is an enormous palaver. You need very, very sharp razors and you need someone
是的，那个3D模型。我的意思是，他看起来非常非常阴险。无论如何，要么你刮得精光，要么你的胡子经过修剪、修饰和造型。是的。而这带来的必然结果是，不修边幅的胡子越来越多地成为平民阶层的一个标志。这反映了这样一个事实：其实我们直到现在还没怎么谈到过，刮胡子是一件极其麻烦的事情。你需要非常非常锋利的剃须刀，而且你需要有人
who is competent to shave you. And the risk of being kind of nicked, there's no antiseptic or anything. It's exceedingly dangerous. As we will see in the next episode, Tom, because already it's very clear this is going to be a two-episode story, this is a risk running right into the 20th century, that a shaving cut can literally mean death. Yes, and that's why for the Romans, a tonsil, a shaver, is analogous to a celebrity chef, because you want nothing but the best. You're putting your life in the hands of this slave, so it needs to be really, really good. And most people,
谁有资格为你刮胡子。而且还有被刮伤的风险，又没有防腐剂或什么东西。这极其危险。正如我们将在下一集中看到的，汤姆，因为很明显这将是一个两集的故事，这是一个一直延续到20世纪的风险，刮胡子的伤口字面意思可能意味着死亡。是的，这就是为什么对于罗马人来说，一个理发师、一个刮胡匠，类似于一位名厨，因为你只想要最好的。你把自己的生命交在这个奴隶手里，所以它必须真的、真的非常好。而大多数人，
of course, can't afford that, but they can go to the tonstrina, so the kind of the public barbers. And the barber there has a role analogous to a barber surgeon in kind of medieval or early modern times. They will extract teeth as well as do your shaving cut your hair trim your your fingernails their skill is what it's all about and the more skill you have the better you will be so by the end of the first century a.d beginning of the second century a.d beards in the roman world are massively out of fashion. And the person who then reintroduces it, so in antiquity, probably second only to Alexander in his influence on beardology, is Hadrian. And this is because of his enthusiasm. Well, have I made this up? Is it his enthusiasm for
当然，负担不起这个，但他们可以去公共理发店（tonstrina）。那里的理发师的角色类似于中世纪或近代早期的理发外科医生。他们会拔牙，也会为你刮胡子、剪头发、修剪指甲，他们的手艺就是一切，你的手艺越好，你就会越好，因此到了公元一世纪末公元二世纪初，罗马世界的胡须极其不流行。然后重新引入它的人，在古代，对胡须学的影响可能仅次于亚历山大，那就是哈德良。这是因为他的热情。好吧，我是不是编造了这个？是出于他对
Greece or is he trying to cover up an unpleasant skin complaint? So the idea that he had terrible acne has always been a popular one, for which I think there's no evidence at all. I think Hadrian, like Alexander, is brilliant at self-promotion. And he is appealing to those who admire philosophy. So we heard he's a student of Stoic philosophers. And so by doing that, he is signaling his enthusiasm for those philosophical traditions
希腊的热情，还是他试图掩盖令人不快的皮肤问题？因此，他患有可怕的痤疮这一观点一直很受欢迎，我认为这根本没有证据。我认为哈德良和亚历山大一样，在自我宣传方面非常出色。他吸引了那些崇拜哲学的人。所以我们听说他是斯多葛派哲学家的一名学生。因此，通过这样做，他表达了他对那些先于亚历山大的哲学传统的热情
that precede Alexander. The beard is also, as we said, a plebeian marker, particularly of the legionaries. By wearing a beard, he's casting himself as the friend of the legions when he goes on his tours of the frontier, and as a philhellene a lover of greek culture when he's going on his tours of athens and alexandria so it's it's kind of brilliant marketing yeah and it becomes very influential so the emperors who follow him marcus aurelius most famously i mean they are all wearing beards and they're all doing marcus aurelius is very into his kind of stoic philosophy very into this idea that a man properly should have a beard because it's an expression of the hot fluids and the semen in his body. And this is the age when Galen, the great medical writer,
胡须正如我们所说，也是一个平民的标志，尤其是军团士兵的标志。通过留胡子，当他在边境巡视时，他将自己塑造成军团的朋友；当他在雅典和亚历山大巡视时，他是一个热爱希腊文化的爱好者（philhellene），所以这是一种非常出色的营销，是的，它变得非常有影响力，因此跟随他的皇帝——最著名的马可·奥勒留——这意味着他们都留着胡子，他们都在这样做，马可·奥勒留非常沉迷于他的斯多葛哲学，非常沉迷于这样一种观点：一个男人应该留胡子，因为这是他体内炎热体液和精液的表达。这是盖伦，这位伟大的医学作家的时代，
is reviving those Aristotelian traditions and using it to offer as a kind of scientific proof the physical superiority of men over women so nature galen argues doesn't give women beards and this then proves that they lack the nobility of character that a man has but also this is the age of i mean rome's under great pressure on the frontiers it's an age of kind of balkan soldier emperors isn't it yes jockovich type yeah strong men and you strong man every six months and they all have beards by and large i mean the beard is part of the package again because they are marking themselves out as soldiers yeah up until the third century the legati the the commanders of the legions they are doing it you know they are
正在复兴这些亚里士多德传统，并用它来作为一种科学证明，证明男性的身体优越于女性，盖伦认为，自然界不给女性长胡子，这随后证明了她们缺乏男性的高贵品质，但这也是一个时代，也就是说罗马边境压力巨大，这是一个由巴尔干士兵皇帝组成的时代，不是吗？是的，像约科维奇那样，对的，硬汉，你每六个月就会有一个硬汉，而且他们大体上都有胡子，我的意思是，胡子也是这个组合的一部分，因为他们将自己标榜为士兵。是的，直到第三世纪，指挥官们（legati），军团的指挥官们，他们都是
civilians they are noblemen they are people who are climbing up the ladder of advancement. And so a military command for them is like a consulship or a quaestorship. But from the third century onwards, such is the strain that the empire is coming under, that to mark yourself as permanently a soldier, someone who is not part of the aristocratic civilian tradition. It's a reassurance to people. The emperor is someone who knows what he's doing. And likewise, when at the end of the third century, going into the fourth, you start to get a measure of stability, and then the empire is really very strongly stabilized under Constantine the Great. Constantine shows himself as shaved because he's essentially saying, you know, we're back to the golden age. We're back to an age of peace. We're back to an age when civilians are in charge. But then his nephew is Julian the Apostate.
平民，他们是贵族，他们是正在晋升阶梯上往上爬的人。因此，对他们来说，军事指挥就像执政官或财务官一样。但从第三世纪开始，帝国承受着巨大的压力，以至于将自己永久标榜为一名士兵，一个不属于贵族平民传统的人。这给人们一种安心感。皇帝是一个知道自己在做什么的人。同样，当在第三世纪末，进入第四世纪时，你开始获得一定程度的稳定，然后帝国在大帝君士坦丁的统治下真正得到了非常强烈的稳定。君士坦丁表现自己是刮过胡子的，因为他本质上是在说，你知道，我们回到了黄金时代。我们回到了一个和平的时代。我们回到了一个由平民掌权的时代。但随后他的侄子是背教者尤利安。
He wants to turn back the clock to a pre-Christian Roman empire, famously. He's a great man for a beard, isn't he? Oh, he loves a beard. Yeah. So he goes to Antioch, which is full of clean-shaven types, and they all jeer at him. And Julian's furious about this. And he writes a satire called The Mizo Pogon, The Beard Hater, where he goes all in. He condemns his critics in antioch as effeminate terrible you know completely lacking the hot bodily fluids that are that that a real man should have yeah and he's very keen to see beards restored to their rightful place as he sees it but as with his paganism this is really the kind of the last hurrah of traditional Hellenic beard enthusiasm. Because even now I equate paganism with beards,
众所周知，他想把时钟拨回到前基督教的罗马帝国。他是一个非常喜欢胡子的人，不是吗？哦，他太喜欢胡子了。所以他去了安条克，那里到处都是刮得精光的家伙，他们都嘲笑他。尤利安对此勃然大怒。他写了一部名为《厌须者》（The Misopogon）的讽刺作品，在其中他全力以赴。他谴责安条克批评他的人软弱、可怕，你知道，完全缺乏一个真正的男人应该拥有的温热体液，是的，他非常渴望看到胡子恢复到他所认为的应有地位，但正如他的异教信仰一样，这实际上是传统希腊胡须热情的最后狂欢。因为即使现在我也把异教与胡子等同起来，
which is strange actually because the only pagan I know is Ronald Hudson, who's been on our podcast. He doesn't have a beard. But he does have kind of long hair, doesn't he? All right, let's talk about Christianity. So Constantine the Great, he's a tremendous point to move to Christianity. So Jesus, you and I were discussing this before the podcast uh you corrected me and said because i believe that jesus was clean shaven no he was i imagine
这其实很奇怪，因为我认识的唯一的异教徒是罗纳德·哈德森，他曾上过我们的播客。他没有胡子。但他确实有点长头发，对吧？好吧，我们来谈谈基督教。所以大帝君士坦丁，他是转向基督教的一个巨大的转折点。所以耶稣，你和我之前在播客里讨论过这个，你纠正了我，说因为我相信耶稣是刮过胡子的，不，他是，我想象
jesus looking very much like me but this is wrong you tell me and that jesus actually because i always thought the beard was a kind of medieval innovation. So it is true that the earliest portrayal of Jesus, which comes from a villa in Dorset, shows him as clean-shaven. Case closed. That for several centuries after that, so up until the fifth century really, he is almost by default shown as not having a beard. This isn't because, as is often said, that Christians want to associate Jesus with Apollo or some god like that. It's not about that. It's because he's the emperor of heaven. So just as Constantine is showing himself clean-shaven, he's the ruler of a united,
耶稣长得很像我，但这不对，你告诉我，耶稣实际上是因为我一直以为胡子是一种中世纪的创新。所以确实，最早的耶稣画像位于多塞特郡的一座别墅中，画中的他刮得精光。案件告破。在那之后的几个世纪里，实际上直到五世纪，他几乎默认都是没有胡子的。这不是像人们常说的那样，基督徒想把耶稣与阿波罗或类似的神联系起来。不是因为这个。这是因为他是天堂的皇帝。正如君士坦丁展现自己刮过胡子一样，他是一个统一的、
peaceful world. So Christ, as the emperor of heaven, to be clean shaven he's in the dimension of the holy of the divine of the angelic but of course while also being divine he's also human the famous church in ravenna built by by theodoric yeah the austro-gothic king who was arian and so had dodgy views on the relationship of the divine and the human in the figure of Christ. On there, Christ is shown with bearded humans, and he is shown as being clean-shaven. Then he's shown among angels following the resurrection, and there he's shown bearded. Obviously, it's a way of saying he's simultaneously human and divine. Even though Theoderic is viewed as heretical by the Romans who recover Italy under Justinian, Justinian is fiercely orthodox, those mosaics remain. And so it is expressive of
和平的世界的统治者。所以基督，作为天堂的皇帝，为了刮过胡子，他处于神圣的、神圣的、天使的维度，但当然，他在具有神圣性的同时也是人类。拉文纳著名的教堂由狄奥多里克建造，狄奥多里克是东哥特国王，他是阿里乌斯派，因此对基督的神圣与人性之间的关系有着古怪的看法。在那上面，基督与留着胡子的人类一起被描绘，他被描绘成刮过胡子。然后他被描绘在复活后的大天使中间，在那里他被描绘成留着胡子的。很明显，这是一种说法，即他同时是人又是神。尽管在查士丁尼收复意大利的罗马人看来，狄奥多里克被视为异端，查士丁尼是坚定的正统派，但那些马赛克依然存在。因此，它表达了
this notion that Christ is both, you know, he's simultaneously human, simultaneously divine. Simultaneously bearded and clean-shaven. So it's going back to Shulgi, the Sumerian king who has himself shown in exactly that way. It's dealing with the fact that a great king, and I suppose Christ for a Christian is the greatest of all kings, has to be shown as both. And how do you do that visually? Now, of course, it's true that by the 6th century, the image of Christ as bearded is starting to become conventional. So it's starting to appear on icons.
这样一个概念：基督既是，你知道的，他同时是人，同时又是神。既留有胡子又刮过胡子。所以这可以追溯到苏美尔国王舒尔吉，他让人们以这种确切的方式描绘自己。它处理这样一个事实：一个伟大的王，我想基督对基督徒来说是所有王中最伟大的，必须被描绘成兼具两者。你在视觉上怎么做到这一点呢？现在，当然，到了公元6世纪，将基督描绘成留着胡子的形象开始成为一种惯例。所以它开始出现在圣像上。
And I think there's two reasons for that. One of them is that there is a description of Christ as bearded in the Bible, but it doesn't come in the New Testament. It comes in the Old Testament where the prophet Isaiah, he's giving this portrayal of the suffering servant, as it's called. It's a prophetic vision that Christians assume is a portrayal of Christ. And in that, Isaiah is giving voice to the suffering servant. And the suffering servant says, they plucked out my beard. And this is interpreted as being part of the tortures that Christ undergoes during his passion before he's being nailed up on the cross. So that offers biblical sanction
我认为有两个原因。其中之一是《圣经》中对留着胡子的基督有描述，但它不是在新约中。它在旧约中，先知以赛亚在那里对被称为受苦仆人的形象进行了描绘。这是一个基督徒认为是基督写照的预言异象。在其中，以赛亚发出了受苦仆人的声音。受苦仆人说：“他们拔掉了我的胡子。”这被解释为基督在受难期间，在被钉上十字架之前所遭受的酷刑的一部分。因此，这提供了圣经上的支持
for his having a beard. I'd be honest, I don't find that conclusive, but some people may. Well, let's just say that by the sixth century, people are starting to find that conclusive, and you can take it up with the church fathers. I will do. But I think the other way is that they are doing what the Egyptians did with the pharaohs, showing them as simultaneously trying to portray them in a way that evokes a sense of being clean shaven while having a beard. Okay. And perhaps it's telling.
因为他留着胡子。老实说，我发现这并不具有决定性，但有些人可能会。好吧，我们只能说，到了公元6世纪，人们开始觉得这很有说服力，你可以和教会之父们去理论。我会的。但我认为另一种方式是，他们正在做埃及人对法老所做的事情，将他们描绘成同时试图以一种唤起既刮过胡子又留着胡子的感觉的方式来刻画他们。好的。也许这说明了什么。
I mean, I don't know. It probably isn't. But it is interesting that the kind of the classic early example of this comes from St. Catherine's Monastery in the Sinai, so very, very close to Egypt, where the beard is, it's not a kind of Zeus-like beard. It's a closer beard. It's a shorter beard. And that, I guess, is the image of Christ that people would have to this day. That's how he's portrayed. It's not a kind of massive, great... It's not Karl Marx's beard.
我的意思是，我不知道。可能不是。但有趣的是，这种早期经典例子的发源地来自西奈山的圣凯瑟琳修道院，离埃及非常非常近，那里的胡子，不是那种类似宙斯的胡子。它是更贴面部的胡子。它是更短的胡子。我想，这就是人们直到今天对基督的印象。这就是他的描绘方式。这不是那种巨大的、伟大的……这不是卡尔·马克斯的胡子。
It's not a Karl Marx, it's not a WG Grace beard. It's a kind of shorter beard. Yeah. Beard of a West German footballer at the 1982 World Cup. That's the kind of beard it is. Okay. I'll take your word for it. So you might think that that would provide Christians with a kind of model if it's good enough for their Lord and Saviour. Why wouldn't it be good enough for them? Yeah. And I think that in the Orthodox world, so the Eastern regions of the Roman Empire and then Christians under Islam, that association of godliness with a beard continues. So Greek Orthodox priests to this day have beards. It's different in Latin Christendom because there the connotations of beards and lack of beards becomes much more complicated and kind of bound up with all kinds of developments through the early Middle Ages and
这不是卡尔·马克斯的，这不是WG·格雷斯的胡子。这是一种较短的胡子。是的。1982年世界杯西德足球运动员的胡子。这就是那种胡子。好吧。我听你的。所以你可能会认为这会为基督徒提供一种模式，如果它对他们的主和救世主足够好。为什么对他们不够好呢？是的。我认为在东正教世界，即罗马帝国的东部地区以及伊斯兰教统治下的基督徒，神性与胡子的这种联系一直在继续。因此，希腊东正教神父至今仍然留着胡子。拉丁基督教世界的情况则不同，因为在那里，有胡子和没有胡子的含义变得更加复杂，并与整个中世纪早期和
into the high Middle Ages. And I wonder whether one of the reasons for that, so the association that comes to develop there of being clean-shaven with godliness isn't influenced by the Viking raids. Really? The fact that the Vikings are kind of so unapologetically pagan and hairy that monks in particular, but also priests, come to associate beards with the savagery of the heathen. That's interesting, because I was reading a book about the Vikings, which I know you've read as well. It's called Embers of the Hands by Eleanor Barraclough, who's been on this podcast,
中世纪盛期的各种发展交织在一起。我想知道其中的原因之一，即在那里发展起来的光洁无须与神性的联系，是否受到了维京人袭击的影响。真的吗？维京人是如此毫不掩饰地是异教徒且毛发浓密，以至于僧侣们，尤其是牧师们，开始将胡子与异教徒的野蛮联系在一起。这很有趣，因为我正在读一本关于维京人的书，我知道你也读过。它是由曾做客本播客的埃莉诺·巴拉克拉夫（Eleanor Barraclough）所写的《手烬》（Embers of the Hands），
and she talks a lot about combs and about viking hair the vikings shaved their heads at the back and then had these kind of floppy new romantic fringes and wore beards and wore beards and the anglo-saxons had mustaches and just had and had longer hair and obviously saw the beard as unsettlingly alien. So I wonder about that. And certainly by the early ninth century, so this is pretty early on into the Viking age. So it's issued by Louis the Pious,
她谈到了许多关于梳子和维京人头发的事情。维京人把脑后的头发剃光，然后留着这种软塌塌的新浪漫主义刘海，还留着胡子。而盎格鲁-撒克逊人留着八字胡，只是留着较长的头发，显然认为胡子具有令人不安的异域感。所以我对此很好奇。当然，到了公元九世纪初，也就是维京时代相当早的时候。因此，这是由路易虔诚者（Louis the Pious）发布的，
who was the son of Charlemagne in the early ninth century, that throughout Frankish lands, beards on monks are kind of legally forbidden, that monks should be clean shaven. And this generates, obviously, a kind of sense of fashion. People who want to display their zeal, their Christian zeal, start to shave. So there's a Muslim traveler to Rome a few decades later, after Louis the Pious has brought in this dictate, who is appalled at how clean-shaven everybody in Rome is. And he
他是查理曼大帝的儿子，在公元九世纪初，整个法兰克土地上，在法律上禁止僧侣留胡子，僧侣必须刮得精光。这显然产生了一种时尚感。那些想要展示他们的热情，他们的基督教热情的人，开始刮胡子。因此，在路易虔诚者颁布这项法令几十年后，有一位到访罗马的穆斯林旅行者，他对罗马每个人都刮得精光感到震惊。并且他
sees this association of hairlessness with godliness correctly, I think, as contrary to Christian as well as to Muslim tradition. This is then further sharpened by the great revolutionary moment in medieval history, which of course, by King Charles' head, is the 11th century, the Gregorian reform. What Gregory VII and his fellow reformers are trying to do is to usher in a great process of purification that will embrace the entirety of the Christian people. For Gregory, the people who have to do this, it's not just the monks, it's the priests as well. Gregory is very keen on the idea that priests should also be clean-shaven. what he always does when he introduces a kind of radical reform,
正确地认为，这种将无毛与神性联系起来的做法，与基督教以及伊斯兰教的传统背道而驰。这种做法随后在中世纪历史的重大革命时刻得到了进一步加剧，当然，以国王查理的头颅来看，这就是11世纪的格里高利改革。格里高利七世和他的同僚改革者们试图做的是开启一个伟大的净化过程，这个过程将涵盖整个基督教人民。对格里高利来说，必须做到这一点的人，不仅是僧侣，还有神职人员。格里高利非常热衷于神职人员也应该刮光胡子的想法。当他引入某种激进的改革时，他总是这样做，
so it's the Gregorian reform that is also demanding that priests as well as monks be celibate, he's always kind of saying, this is the way it was always done. This is the venerable tradition of the church going back to the beginning. It's reinventing history. Yeah, exactly. He's rewriting history. He's kind of foregrounding what is quite a radical reform, quite a radical idea back in the roots of time. And so in the 11th century, this association of purity with a clean-shaven chin becomes absolutely embedded. It's not just priests who are taking this up. So you talked about
所以正是格里高利改革也要求神父和修道士一样保持独身，他总是说，事情一直都是这样的。这是教会追溯到开端的古老传统。这是在重塑历史。是的，完全正确。他在改写历史。他把一个相当激进的改革、一个相当激进的想法推到了时间的根源。所以在11世纪，这种将纯洁与光洁下巴联系在一起的想法变得完全根深蒂固。不仅仅是神父们在接受这一点。所以你谈到了
the Anglo-Saxons having moustaches. If you think of the Bayeux Tapestry, the Normans are clean-shaven. The fact that they are clean-shaven is emblematic of the role that they are playing as the kind of cutting edge of this reformatio, this process of reform that Gregory VII is embodying. So again, the way in which beards and moustaches and shaving them off or keeping them are expressive of a kind of cultural identity. You see it really, really strongly in this most turbulent of all the centuries of medieval Christian Europe. And as you intimated at the start of this episode, it does kind of take you back to the beginnings, to that kind of Sumerian Egyptian idea that being shaved brings you closer to the dimension of the holy. Well, Tom, that is a theme that will run right through our next episode. But also you've
盎格鲁-撒克逊人留着八字胡。如果你想想巴约挂毯，诺曼人都是刮得精光的。他们刮得精光这一事实象征着他们正在扮演的角色，即格里高利七世所体现的这场宗教改革（reformatio）、这场改革过程的前沿。所以同样，胡子、八字胡以及把它们刮掉或留着的这种方式，是如何表达一种文化认同的。你在中世纪基督教欧洲所有这些最动荡的世纪中，非常非常强烈地看到了这一点。正如你在本集开头所暗示的那样，它确实把你带回了起点，回到了苏美尔和埃及的那种观念中，即刮胡子使你更接近神圣的维度。好吧，汤姆，这将是贯穿我们下一集的一个主题。但你也
very brilliantly queued up what will be the great theme of that episode. And actually, in some ways, the theme of our entire engagement with history. And that is the question that's hung over this podcast from the very earliest days. Should Englishmen have beards? So we'll be back to discuss that. We'll be discussing Peter the Great, the Crimean War. We'll be talking about Shakespearean beards, the Beatles and beards. Hipsters. Why Churchill didn't have a beard. We'll be addressing these and other questions in the next episode. If you want to listen to that episode, Tom, what could people do? They could go to therestishistory.com and sign up there.
非常精彩地为那一集的主题做好了铺垫。事实上，在某些方面，这也是我们整个历史探索的主题。这就是从早期开始一直悬在这个播客之上的问题：英国人应该留胡子吗？所以我们将回来讨论这个问题。我们将讨论彼得大帝、克里米亚战争。我们将讨论莎士比亚式的胡子、披头士乐队和胡子。嬉皮士。为什么丘吉尔不留胡子。我们将在下一集中探讨这些及其他问题。如果你想听那一集，汤姆，大家可以做什么？他们可以访问 therestishistory.com并在那里注册。
Of course they could. That's what they could do. They could absolutely do that. I don't think we've ever mentioned that before, but that is what they can do. Yeah. And all that stunning bombshell. Goodbye. Bye-bye.
他们当然可以。这就是他们能做的。他们绝对可以做到这一点。我想我们以前从未提到过这一点，但这确实是他们能做的。是的。所有这些令人惊艳的重磅炸弹。再见。拜拜。
I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦以及在我们的问答环节中必不可少的节目
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。